as long as man has told stories there
has been folklore tall tales and in the
Modern Age urban legends more recently
the Advent of the internet has resulted
in an explosion of stories often
referred to as Creepy Pasta the most
well-known creepy pastas such as Slender
Man Jeff the Killer and the Russian
sleep experiment were usually fictional
stories originally created by Anonymous
internet users using a pseudonim but the
lore is often times built upon by the
internet Community usually the result is
that the original author loses control
of his or her creation and that seems to
be what happens in 2012 in the case of
smiley usually that only happens when
the story is good to begin with but
Smiley has proven that there are
exceptions to learn how YouTubers made a
horror movie so controversial that it
had to be wiped off the face of the
internet and how the legacy of smiley
still persists today stick around to the
end of this
[Music]
video Welcome to Horror
history I did this one for the LOLs
Smiley is the 2012 horror Masterpiece
directed by Michael Gallagher who
created the OG YouTube channel totally
sketch as you can tell by the name it
was a sketch comedy collective in the
era of oversaturated and racy thumbnails
in the early days on YouTube it was a
really big deal and would often feature
guest appearances from some of the
biggest creators on the internet Michael
also has an impressive resume of viral
videos he directed for other channels
and his connection to Big creators seems
to be the entire impetus behind the
creation of his first narrative feature
well okay I won't say the entire impetus
Smiley deals with themes surrounding the
pitfalls of online stranger danger and
the darkest communities on the web
something that Gallagher is qualified to
make a movie about being an internet
Creator himself there are at least 10
YouTubers or YouTube adjacent people in
this movie that I spotted which I'll
point out as they come up in the story
however I too am an internet Creator and
for that reason I am qualified to talk
about it but I am not the first they
dropped the ball pretty early on if you
want to see a movie that's boring I got
just the thing for you it's so stupid
just made probably the worst plot that
I've ever seen in a movie don't tell
anybody else in this movie yeah it
sucked end of video thanks for watching
but does Smiley deserve all that the
hates is there actually something to
this movie that others aren't seeing how
can a character who is still being
celebrated 11 years later really be that
bad to understand Smiley we've got to
take it back to the group that turned
Smiley from scary story to Supernatural
stock most good movies are able to
thrive on the strength of a captivating
script dynamic characters Stellar acting
and Innovative directing most master
classes of Cinema do not need to open
with a nice ass shot to catch the
viewers attention but there are
exceptions I am of course talking about
lost in translations but Smiley can live
up to that too right this is Stacy and
she's the First on our YouTube account
because she's played by Nikki limo from
totally sketch okay we get it this is
the only way they know how to hold the
viewers attention Stacy is part of a
group of actors from the online
Collective Anonymous who have gotten
together at Pacific Valley University in
Los Angeles to start a new viral Trend
using the internet they spread rumors of
a killer named Smiley a man who
supposedly spited his eyes shut and
carved himself a permanent smile with a
knife start a video chat with somebody
who you don't even know and you type in
I did it for the blls three times and
then this guy with the knife appears
behind them and what they die so the
anonymous group seems to be staging some
videos where users on both ends are
their members and these videos naturally
get spread around the college and the
internet and the legend grows other than
Stacy the smiley group consists of seven
other main players Kell's is played by
Richard Ryan who was also part of
totally sketch but is most known for his
gun Channel full mag where he blew up
smartphones and gaming consoles this guy
who is only known as flasher you'll see
why in a minute is played by Jason
Horton who was part of totally sketch
and had a small solo career where he
transitioned from sex bait comedy to
True Crime then there's Zayn the party
guy who can often be spotted with two
friends trash is played by Steve Green
from you guessed it totally sketch Steve
married Nikki limo in 2017 and they
currently do a podcast together the
other friend is named decepticon and
played by day Storm Power Day storm was
one of the biggest self-made musicians
on early YouTube Roxy also known as
proxy seems to be secretly dating Zayn
in the movie that is and finally there's
binder who's seemingly the leader of the
group and The Mastermind behind the plan
he's played by Shane Dawson one of the
biggest names in comedy then and the
biggest name in conspiracy theory
exploration today kind of funny to think
that this movie was maybe like his first
conspiracy theory thing that he did by
the way these shirts are available in my
merch store link below anyway these
eight make up the smiley group and
they're willing to do anything to spread
fear about Smiley but making a bunch of
fake viral videos will only give the
character so much notoriety so they
decide that they need to actually get
someone killed Roxy has a two-bedroom
house near the college campus so she
puts up a listing looking for a roommate
and chooses a victim out of the
applicants and they end up selecting
Ashley a new incoming student Ashley is
book smart but she has no common sense
so she's easy to manipulate she also has
a history of mental illness in her
family and I'm guessing that the smiley
group knew about that and it contributed
to them selecting her their first goal
was to get Ashley to believe in Smiley
but what they didn't realize was that
smiley was not as made up as they
thought
Ashley moves in with Roxy on September
12th one day before we see this alarm
clock a later shot makes it look like
the year is 2012 though it's kind of
blurry because I was only able to get
this movie on DVD it's not available for
streaming anywhere more on that later
Ashley's dad helps her move into the new
place but she only has one box of
belongings apparently also Ashley's dad
looks exactly like her dad from
Insidious the last key even though it's
not the same actor text me if you need
anything I think I'll just call probably
a good idea yes because texting is too
high tech for a man in his 60s in the
year 2012 like maybe you could make that
joke in like 2003 2004 but 2012 he's not
texting yet it kind of feels like
there's an intentional theme here like
they're trying to say technology bad
technology dangerous but calling is also
technology Roxy invites her new roommate
to come to a party and we see that
Ashley is not very rebellious initially
hesitant about partying on a school
night before awkwardly accepting and
shaking her roommate's hand for some
reason yes I accept your
invitation lovely an interesting detail
about their living situation is that
Roxy apparently found her online and was
stoked to meet someone normal again
playing into the fears of you don't know
who strangers really are online and then
this immediately comes up again when
Roxy claims that she's never met the
people having the party no look I know
them okay I just haven't met them in
person this guy from be invited La
people to his house for meet up I guess
I should probably explain what B is in
case some people don't know B is an
image board on the Forum 4chan where
anything goes as long as it doesn't
break the law forchan as you may know is
completely Anonymous which feeds into
the theme of online stranger danger B is
the most notorious for on forchan or
maybe the entire internet it has a
reputation for grotesque material and
its users are known to band together in
the name of trolling including
everything from getting for chance
founder voted in as times person of the
year to convincing teenagers that there
was a movement to post self harm
pictures and solidarity with Justin
Bieber because he had cancer spoiler
alert he didn't have cancer so they go
into the party and this is the
party I guess I shouldn't have expected
much more out of a room of for channers
but this looks very awkward it's hosted
by Zayn who meets them and immediately
suggests a threesome within the first 20
seconds of knowing them I mean I guess
he secretly knows Roxy but uh yeah not
socially adjusted he also tells them
about his area of research at the
University no but uh really what I'm
interested in is how people start
believing in things you know like uh
Bigfoot for example you know there's no
evidence that Bigfoot exists yet lots of
people believe in Bigfoot this is
evidence that this movie is just like
the 1992 classic Candyman except made
for an audience in the digital age in
Candyman the main character Helen Lyle
was a graduate student doing her thesis
on urban legends and she attended a
class at the beginning talking about the
same topic what causes people to believe
in these stories and now why would Danny
and Diane both be suffering from the
same delusion in Two Cities over a
thousand miles apart see these stories
are modern oral folklore they are the
unselfconscious reflection of the fears
of urban Society also Roxy is just
inexplicably crying in this one take
which is kind of concerning maybe this
was the first scene that they filmed and
she just had this realization that she's
one of the few cast members of this
movie who isn't a YouTuber and unlike
them her career is going to be
completely ruined by this many of the
YouTubers in this movie would have their
careers ruined but being in Smiley 2012
wasn't exactly the reason behind it
speaking of which oh hey I I think I saw
that guy on campus yo they didn't they
actually put him in a movie so in order
to I don't know better sell the illusion
that smiley is real binder and Zayn act
like they don't know each other so I
guess whoever Ashley sides with can be
the one to manipulate her hey hey what's
up I'm Zane what's up I'm binder yeah
what are you doing here Peta bear don't
call me that which is very interesting
foreshadowing because in 2018 some
people took podcast Clips where Shane
was clearly just joking around and
reposted small portions of them out of
context to make him look like a pedo I'm
not condoning anything he said by the
way but it is pretty clear that the
clips were edited to make him look worse
you can even see some of that classic
Shane style of humor while promoting
this movie now I have something to do on
Halloween which is go see Smiley because
usually I just sit at home I pass out
candy but technically I'm not supposed
to be within 50 ft of children so I I
more throw out candy as a result of the
scandalous jokes he had to make this
response video it was a pretty big deal
in the world of YouTube drama I'm going
to start by saying I am not a pedophile
and while he's still doing very well his
views have not been the same since this
went down anyway after Shane I mean
binder is kicked out of the party the
girls noticed some guys on a website
called hide and go chat which is
basically an omegal esque site that
pairs you up with a random stranger on
video chat only this is not a random
stranger it's Stacy oh no is this that
site where it just chooses who you talk
with yeah H go chat yeah you really
shouldn't be on the site it's for people
that do gross things to other people
which was very much the case on omegal
according to its reputation as I was
writing this video omegel was actually
shut down after 14 years of operation as
part of a lawsuit involving child
exploitation Smiley seems to be an
allegory for the potential harm that can
come out of a sight where users are
paired anonymously and this film isn't
shy about referencing this just like
they aren't shy about the totally sketch
Easter eggs people use this to find
dates yeah a lot of guys do it some of
them even do it with their pants off
okay see that's why you shouldn't be on
the site it's way too sketch totally
crash types I did it for the luls into
the chat three times times and someone
in a smiley mask appears behind her and
pretends to stab her I'm pretty sure
there's an error in the movie because at
first we see her saying I did it for the
LOLs but it's supposed to be him saying
it and then when we cut to the wide shot
it's fixed so it's kind of confusing as
to who actually said it and this would
have been the easiest pickup shot to fix
because it literally doesn't require any
actors or crew literally just a camera
and a computer screen but they didn't
bother fixing it and it's really the
perfect preview of what the quality of
this movie is going to be like but from
Ashley's point of view someone in a
cloth Smiley mask sneaks up behind the
girl on the screen and stabs her at
super fast forward speed which doesn't
make sense considering that we
eventually find out that this was staged
by a human and Stacy is later revealed
to be alive meaning that what we see
here was definitely faked it seems like
for the most part the smiley group uses
these masks covered in cloth whereas the
real Smiley who we haven't met yet just
has this smooth skin face with stitches
on it Ashley being the unfathomably
gullible freshman that she is
immediately freaks out and assumes it
was real it's like Bloody Mary okay it's
an urban legend you type I did it for
the lws three times across from some
you're chatting with and then smiley
creeps
this is another parallel to Candyman
which is also partially inspired by
Bloody Mary in Candyman you summon him
by saying his name in the mirror five
times in Smiley you type the phrase into
the chat three times to summon him the
webcam even kind of serves as a mirror
because you see yourself and the person
you're chatting with and like every
Candyman movie the next day things would
get real as Ashley would try summoning
the evil for
[Music]
herself
the following day September 13th Ashley
was late to her first class one of her
classmates is Mark played by Toby Turner
aka Tobuscus who used to be one of the
biggest channels on YouTube for his
skits gaming and Vlogs why do you think
do the girl he's trying to flirt with is
played by Michael Gallagher's girlfriend
and later wife Janna winternet even the
teacher has sort of a YouTube connection
he's played by Roger Bart who is dating
professional tantrum H Trisha pis AKA
blind Sund doll for MJ when Ashley gets
home Roxy informs her that a new Smiley
video is surfaced the video is titled
Smiley kills drunk dude and it fills me
with Nostalgia to see the good old
yellow subscribe button on YouTube
anyway we see a cloth mask version of
smiley kill off Kel's who they had met
at the party last night Ashley is scared
but Roxy suggests that they try
summoning Smiley in order to find out if
he's fake or not we just do it nothing
happens and then we know it's fake
because that way we'll know it's fake
for
sure okay for someone who apparently
does all her homework assignments from
the beginning of of the semester Ashley
is really not smart they scroll through
hide and go chat until they get to a
flasher this is flasher who I mentioned
earlier and they decide to test the
ritual out on him apparently every
character in the smiley universe is just
so horny that they literally can't think
about anything else like even after she
threatens to kill him he's just like
make out with each other so Ashley types
the cursed phrase three times and then
this
happens this is the most elaborate or
lucky part of the plan because it had to
work out to where Ashley decided to kill
this particular guy the guy who was a
plant it's possible that since the
smiley group are hackers they were able
to manipulate things on the website so
that Ashley and flasher would definitely
meet or maybe it's just their websites
but that opens a whole other set of
issues how did they know that she was
going to kill him and how did they know
she wouldn't test it on her own during
the day there are no answers to these
questions it's just not a very well
thought out movie Roxy convinces Ashley
not to go to the police because she
claims Smiley has seen their faces and
calling the police would generate press
and make it easier for the killer to
find them basically it seems like
roxxy's making it seem as if she
believes that there's nothing super
Supernatural going on here but if Smiley
has the ability to show up behind anyone
in the world who receives that message
why would they be treating him as a
regular person who has to use logic and
reasoning to find his victims it's
pretty clear that the only two options
here are that it's staged or that it's
supernatural the next day would be
September 14th in class Ashley draws
Smiley in her notebook and writes I did
it for the luls three times at the top
of her page which seems like a bad idea
because again she believes this is real
and it's not a huge stretch to assume
that if you can summon him by typing the
phrase you could also summon him by
writing it later in the library she runs
into Bender
again and he too has more of a realistic
approach I think Smiley's only real when
people make him real do you think he's
real I don't know if Smiley is real I
mean I think the videos are real that
probably doesn't make any sense no it
really doesn't also they must not have
had many extras for this scene because
the same people keep walking by over and
over but Ashley gets his number and
since he's playing this whole nerd
character he acts like he's literally
never been asked out before what's your
number uh
okay it's awkward when Ashley gets home
Roxy tells her that Zane is having yet
another party this one at least looks
somewhat more like what you would expect
a party to look like but don't worry
because the cinematographer makes up for
it by not framing it like an actual
movie here here oh I proba oh come on
drink it it's free drink I don't know
what's worse the fact that Roxy isn't
facing the same direction between these
two shots or the fact that she's halfway
out of the frame in her coverage or
maybe it's this guy wearing his wardrobe
inside out the scene is filled with
absurd details that are completely
inconsequential I think there was a bug
in it I'm going to go pee in a
closet okay so later on there is this
sign on the bathroom door that says
bathroom no peeing in closet if we had
seen this first it might have made
roxxy's joke land a little bit better
but we don't in fact you're unlikely to
see it at all unless you're looking for
it so the joke comes off as completely
random if you weren't there in 2012 and
by there I mean on the internet there
was very much this meme movement at the
time where random equals funny I like
waffles derp I'm like the most random
person ever like I'm I'm like the king
of Randomness like and it's epic
potato true true I think the perfect
encapsulation of this era on the
Internet is nian cats it came out in
2011 and there's no story behind why
it's just a cat whose body is a Pop-Tart
running through space while emitting a
rainbow Trail while this absolute Bop of
an 8bit Vocaloid song
plays but where nian cat was loved then
and remembered fondly today I have a
feeling Smiley's humor was cringe even
when it came out and seriously how do
you miss the framing this badly half her
head is out of the frame was nobody
looking at the monitor did the camera
operator Stitch his eyes shut after
seeing the quality of the acting Ashley
had come to the party hoping to get her
mind off of smiley but that doesn't last
long as she overhears a conversation
about yet another
[Music]
Victor while Roxy is in the bathroom
Ashley goes over to say hi to Zayn who
is hanging out with crash and deceptic
hoping to maybe find some answers oh hey
what's up hey I'm Ashley yeah yeah I
know we uh we met the other night you
wanted to have sex with me but I wasn't
into it
what yo oh my God bro just dropped the
funniest joke of all time oh you got her
man you got her that one was so funny
this was my least favorite era of Pop
Culture by the way basically they laugh
off her concerns about their missing
cohort it's probably just pulling a
freaking prank on us hello they haven't
even found the body well do you know
where he lives I don't know probably
with his M dude did you just come up
with that wow what an epic joke dude
there there's no way you came up with
that on the spot it seems kind of
counterintuitive for them to mock her
showing actual concern about the video
being real considering that they are
trying to get her to believe that it's
all real like that's their main
objective here right maybe it's like a
reverse psychology thing like she'll
think it's more real if she's the only
one taking it serious ious ly I feel
like that would only work on an idiot
which she is but still crash even
flaunts the truth before her but she's
unable to pick up on it maybe it's the
end of The Truman Show and your boat
just hit the Skyy
old Zayn pulls her aside and they cut to
a shot that's out of focus as he
interrogates her on what she saw where
he's again out of focus then accuses her
of summoning Smiley which he only knows
about because he was in on the plan he
tells her that he has summoned the
grinning antagonist as well claiming
that smiley appeared and sliced up a
random kid this makes Ashley sick to her
stomach and she decides to go home but
before she leaves Zayn continues to
demonstrate the worst timing known to
man you can sleep over which is a weird
play to make on someone who's throwing
up to begin with especially when he just
slammed her with that joke when he said
he wasn't interested in sleeping with
her there was just so much weird going
on in this movie on my letter box I
wrote that this movie was a modern-day
Candyman if Candyman embarrassed itself
and everyone involved every 5 minutes
and that really is true I'm struggling
with what I should include in this video
but like that's too weird not to include
like for example she's going home and
they use this editing technique to make
it look like she's drunk and she
confuses some other person for Roxy
Roxy but that literally looks nothing
like Roxy Ashley was only at that party
for 3 minutes and 58 seconds yes I timed
it if we look back her roommate spilled
her drink immediately and then gave her
this other drink which she took one sip
of then claims that there was a bug in
it so I guess the implication is that
she was ruied and it was Roxy and Zayn's
plan all along to ruy her and have her
encounter smiley on the way home
especially considering this line what if
he comes for the people who call him
have you thought about that so of course
that does happen even though that wasn't
part of the lore at any point before
this but at first this seems to be the
real Smiley based on the fact that she's
approached by this scary figure with the
smooth skinned face and stitched on
features as far as we know this is the
first time that the legend that the
group has created has become real so she
runs home and inside she's attacked by a
fake Smiley someone wearing the cloth
Smiley mask this is all needlessly
confusing and on top of that he grabs
her and she wakes up in the bed the next
morning still screaming for some reason
I'm going to try to look past the
insanity that has been the last 5
minutes of this movie and move on
September 15th Roxy comes in and tries
to calm her down again but Ashley ends
up seeing the school psychiatrist where
we learned that she used to take
medication for bipolar disorder she now
seems convinced that her encounter with
smiley was a dream so I guess roxxy's
dismissive attitude actually worked so
the doctor writes her a prescription for
Adavan to relieve anxiety I just
remembered
something I'm not crazy okay good yeah
immediately after leaving the
psychiatrist office she's greeted by
Roxy who delivers news about a new
Smiley victim number four if you're
keeping count so they go back to Zayn's
again and he's waving around a gun and
reveals he's not a college student he's
a hacker which really doesn't explain
why he's waving around a gun but he
seems to believe that it does who's
doing this we don't know okay well why
don't you riddle me
this who is she me Smiley's trying to
kill me Smiley's trying to kill me dude
that shot was not even close to being in
Focus you cannot just use that in a
movie Zay is worried or at least he's
acting like he's worried that whoever is
behind this is one of the enemies of his
hacking group you don't get to be king
of the internet without making
a few enemies which seems like a
reference to the tagline of the movie
The Social Network which is embarrassing
because the social network is probably
the best movie ever made about the
internet and this may be the worst he
lists off some potential enemies one of
which is the feds the feds could be the
FBI that makes no sense why would the
FBI go around killing col age kids if
they did something to with the FBI I'm
pretty sure the FBI would just arrest
them in the night she has a dream about
a woman sitting by her window which I
think is supposed to be her dead mom but
when she approaches it turns out to be
Smiley but this one seems to actually be
a dream which really just muddies what
happened before I guess maybe that's the
intention to just throw off the audience
however I feel like a good red herring
will make sense at the end like you can
look back at it and say oh yeah now I
understand why we were led to believe
this not the case with smiley what
happens next however seems to offer a
possible explanation for how Smiley came
to be and I I think there's something
that everyone
overlooked we pick back up in another
class and it seems to be the following
week it says Thursday on the board so I
guess we're picking back up on September
20th 2012 let's go with that they're now
talking about philosophy which brings up
another good question what is this class
it's called intro to reason and ethics
and it's required last week it was about
the scientific method and now philosophy
they're talking about aam's Razer or the
principle that the simplest explanation
is usually correct and Tobuscus gets
something right for once now what is the
implication of what I just said it's
almost like everything that happened
happened so we could know it happened
what he's describing is the anthropic
principle the idea that the Universe
seems to be fine-tuned to support the
existence of life even though it's very
unlikely if the laws of the universe
were slightly different there would be
no life and if there was no life there
would be nobody to observe this fact
it's almost as if if we as intelligent
life are supposed to notice that the
Universe operates in a way that supports
life I will give the movie a little bit
of credit here this is a clever lesson
to have Ashley sitting in on because all
of the scenarios that the smiley group
have set up were set up specifically to
make her believe in Smiley it's all a
huge prank on Ashley but she doesn't
notice it she does however have an
interesting conclusion about the
anthropic principle during this lesson
it assumes for the reason when really we
could just be amibas or whatever simple
forms of life were necessary for us to
develop
we might be what's necessary for
something else to develop and her
teacher points out that this may have
already started to happen Humanity may
be nothing more than an intermediate
step in the development of a
Consciousness a trillion times greater
we already built at a network millions
of nodes communicating with each other
that is called the
internet let's just hope that when it
becomes
conscious it's nice to us which I think
is actually an interesting concept it's
probably not for this movie but maybe
something like M3 G Tobuscus and his
girlfriend even bring up a couple of
fictional examples like Terminator and
the Matrix It seems as if this scene is
almost here to suggest that smiley is
the Incarnation of that higher
Consciousness the internet is a series
of interconnected users and we've
already seen several examples of how
that can be harmful not to mention that
the group of internet trolls that come
together to create the fake Smiley are
all from the bbard on forchan which is
Infamous for harnessing the power of
many to troll and do harm like I
mentioned with the Time Magazine pull
and the Justin Bieber cutting th it
could be that the real smile is the
supernatural incarnation of that concept
the same way that Candyman was the
supernatural incarnation of the hurt
caused by racial segregation but
Candyman was covered in bees and had a
hook for a hand because of the torture
that he endured when he was killed so
why does Smiley have a smooth face and
permanently stitched smile well
sometimes the simplest explanation is
the correct one what if it's just
supposed to represent a smiley face
Emoji Emoji are kind of a symbol of the
internet and that would kind of explain
why you summon him by typing I did it
for the LOLs like it's the stupidest
thing ever but it kind of makes sense
binder even kind of hints at this this
later on do you know what this means I I
thought I was crazy but but if this is
true if you're not lying then that means
something's been awakened like
something's been born like Smiley could
be the next generation are you not
listening to me I really kind of like
this whole discussion how it ties into
the false narrative that the four
channers are creating for Ashley and how
it represents what Smiley actually is
the problem is that it's just too smart
for this movie because inside the
classroom Ashley is smart and she's the
one to put this together but then
outside the classroom she's a complete
smooth brain so yeah there's an
interesting concept buried in here
somewhere and nobody noticed it because
most were too busy laughing at it and at
times it's hard to blame them just
remember that smiley was the original
Emoji Movie 5 years before the Emoji
Movie also when I Googled the Emoji
Movie to double check what year it came
out the first thing that caught my eye
was this cast list icon Patrick Stewart
poop which is pretty funny if you think
immature humor is funny which I
absolutely do anyway let's move on
Ashley goes to the library and finally
Googles Smiley urban legend and finds a
video from a little girl whose
babysitter was supposedly killed by
smiling we see what appears to be
smiling Smiley come up and poke her with
a knife but it turns out to just be
Bender but he doesn't have a knife I get
that this is our foreshadowing clue that
he's Smiley and that he was behind at
all but I'm not sure what I as an
audience member am supposed to take away
from that in a literal sense when she
admits that she performed the ritual and
saw someone die his reaction sounds like
one of those old edgy podcast clips that
got him canceled a few years ago I
killed someone are you serious it's
amazing I mean that's terrible obviously
but I try to do it nothing happens she
goes home and clicks through a bunch of
strangers on hide-and go chat for some
reason as usual it's just filled with
horny people until she comes across
someone sitting in the dark who asks if
he should visit her again and claims to
be standing behind her when she turns
around she sees Roxy Who berates her for
going back on the website this is
another kind of foreshadowing clue
because Roxy is also secretly part of
the smiley group she tries calling her
dad for Comfort but Smiley's voice seems
to take over her phone so she returns to
the psychiatrist admits what she really
thinks she saw and they plan to meet the
following day to check her into a clinic
an office visit with her teacher isn't
much help either turns out he's an
alcoholic I'm not really sure what that
adds to the story but they make a point
to highlight it maybe this is too much
of a nitpick but as the teacher explains
his views on evil they're locked face to
face in conversation and we see these
profile shots of each of them but it's
just super off-putting to me how their
heads are centered in the frame rather
than their faces usually as a director
when you compose a frame the negative
space is in the direction that the
character is looking like this profile
shot in Candyman by Framing their heads
like this the result is this shot where
the focal point is Ashley's ear instead
of her F anyway she gets freaked out
when he says is that what is it that the
kid say it's the perfect expression of
nihilism I did it for
the I did it for the ls yeah that's
it I did it for the lulls how are we
supposed to take this seriously later
she's in the library working on a paper
when she hears weird growling in her
headphones and smiley that is the fake
mask version of smiley suddenly appears
on her screen and she responds by
destroying her entire computer rather
than just turning it off or doing a
factory reset making our usual pair of
extras who are in every Library scenes
think that she's insane and some random
Skater Boy Records her breakdown and
puts it online this is actually a
director's Cameo from Michael Gallagher
then in what I'm assuming is another
night because she's wearing completely
different clothes but I wouldn't put it
past this movie to not have the Wardrobe
Department together either Ashley is
Jump scared when someone in the smiley
mask appears behind her in the mirror
but he immediately disappears since this
person is wearing the cloth Smiley mask
but clearly demonstrates the ability to
disappear I'm guessing this was just her
imagination but again with this movie
there's always the option that it was a
mistake and they just used the wrong
mask or something I'm going to assume it
was Ashley starting to lose her mind
because after this she would be driven
to a mental breaking
[Music]
point that night dark dreams clouded
Ashley's head once again this time
involving multiple Smiley Mass killers
in her room and imagery of her mother
turning into Smiley to drool blood on
her upon Awakening in she poses the
question that we've all been wondering
for the last while now is this real or
am I just going
crazy I think both dude so she finally
decides to call the police and they
predictably don't take her seriously at
all I'm going to tell you the part I'm
having a hard time with all of
it Bas he does mention that they've
received a few calls about Smiley and
asked her to consider if she's on the
wrong end of some kind of prank which
she angrily refuses to entertain they
have also seen the video of her smashing
her laptop which has been uploaded as
hot girl goes crazy in library now
remember the one who recorded this video
was the Michael Gallagher insert so is
he making fun of his own channel where
all of his most popular videos have one
thing in common and if you're listening
to this audio only you can look at the
screen right now to see what that one
thing is or does Michael actually see
this as unironically how to do YouTube
the timing of this is also super
interesting because Smiley came out in
2012 that was the year YouTube changed
its algorithm to focus on watch time in
order to help combat clickbait and
promote good content that keeps viewers
engaged there's also another mistake
right here these are the old YouTube
editing features they should have been
logged out to record this because we're
seeing this on the police detective's
computer they would not be logged into
Michael's YouTube account this is
another error that would be easy to fix
in editing like this but they didn't
bother as a last resort Ashley meets
with Bender who gives her an old
computer of his that he set up with all
of the data encrypted and even though
he's still playing the part of the
self-pitying loser she makes a move on
him and they kiss Roxy also claims that
she's going away to her parents house
for the weekend to clear her head so the
stage is set for the final step of their
plan once night has fallen Roxy video
chats her in Panic thinking that
something may have happened to Zayn who
isn't answering her calls Ashley
volunteers to go over to his place to
check on him how convenient that there
was just a flashlight laying on the
floor right in front of the unlocked
door not that you actually tried turning
on the lights I mean the patio lights
seem to work just fine so there's no
reason to believe that the power is out
not to mention that there's music
playing in the distance seriously why
don't you just try the light switch once
she finds the words I did it for the
luls graffitied across the ball and she
discover Zayn apparently covered in
blood on the floor don't worry he's not
dead and it's not real blood so I can
show it also why would you scream when
you see the body the killer could easily
be standing nearby and you just be
calling attention to yourself she finds
all of the monitors in his living room
kind of area glitching out with a video
of the smiley mask behind it all so she
starts destroying them because that
works so well last time right she also
grabs zay's gun which has seemingly been
left out for her much like the
flashlight it seems a little dangerous
to give the person with a history of
psychiatric issues a gun especially when
you're actively trying to make her go
crazy through an elaborate prank that
you're pulling I'm going to give Zayn
the benefit of the doubt and assume that
the gun is filled with blanks and not
real bullets but it still seems like
more trouble than it's worth she returns
home to the video chat with Roxy and
asks her to type I did it for the LOLs
the idea is that they'll summon smiley
behind her and then Ashley can turn
around and shoot him with a gun if
Smiley is real this is a terrible plan
because we literally just established
that Zayn had the gun and he was still
unable to overcome smileing so they go
through with it and Ashley sees someone
coming in through the front door and
fires as soon as he opens it only she
finds out that this wasn't Smiley it was
her night and shining armor Bender never
mind the idea that that he immediately
just tries to enter the house without
knocking or calling even though they've
only known each other for at this point
like 3 weeks and aren't that close yet
how they accomplished their plan is
never explicitly detailed but like I
said I'm guessing the gun was filled
with blanks and Bender was wearing a
squib so he could make it look like she
had shot it honestly I'm going to get
into how this plan is terrible and would
only work if absolutely everything goes
right but let's see the plot through to
the end first Ashley tries to tend to
Bender but that's when someone in a
smiley mask appears from behind him and
slits his throat or so it seems she
probably could have seen him approaching
but whatever she's chased through the
house up to her room where she locks
herself in and waits with the gun drawn
only to realize that someone in a smiley
mask is in the room with her already and
she's all out of bullets she's cornered
by several more Smiley mask killers and
in an act of desperation she jumps
through an absolutely terrible looking
CGI window and Falls to her death or at
least what appears to be her death it's
not that high but she hit her head on
the ground
boys we did it this is kind of
what establishes that they wanted to
kill her the whole time I don't know why
they wanted to kill her and I don't know
why they didn't just throw her out the
window in order to accomplish that I get
that they are forchan posters and they
like chaos or whatever but it seems like
if they wanted to spread the legend of
smiley Ashley could do that for them if
she had survived also it's not clear
what this has to do with Anonymous
they're actually worried that the main
faction of the hacking group won't
approve of their message but binder
argues that because Anonymous is
anonymous that they should get as much
say in the message as anyone else it
seems like overall they just see
themselves as trolls who killed someone
because I mean there's only one reason
to troll
for
L you have got to be kidding me binder
and Zayn go on to explain that smiley
will become immortal because they left
boxes of masks on campus and in 20 other
campuses their belief is that copycats
will start rolling in and the legend
will persist for Generations we'll get
back to that but first there is one
thing that hasn't been taken into
account the smiley group all leave the
house except for Zayn who stays back to
wrap up the video chat with Roxy who is
still on the computer and the camera
goes out of focus on him one last time
because it wouldn't be right to end this
movie without one last up I kind of have
a boner is that weird yes that's weird I
mean I would pose the question why is
this movie so unnecessarily horny but I
think one look at the totally sketched
Channel already answered that Roxy seems
to be the only one who has reservations
about what they did to Ashley she asks
why they did this and Zayn already has
his answer figured out oh well I don't
know why you did it but I know why I did
it he proceeds to type I did it for the
LOLs three times into the chat and is a
gas at the sight of Smiley the real
Smiley appearing behind her and driving
his knife through her face the last
thing he sees is smiley waving at him
before closing the
[Music]
laptop while the ending of smiley fits
right into the slasher genre as a
textbook one last scare moment it really
makes everything that we just witnessed
for the last hour and a half which is
already standing on shaky legs make even
less sense if this were the first time
we had seen real Smiley I could could
understand that it would be him being
born as a real entity for the first time
at the end of the movie but that isn't
what happened because we saw the real
Smiley approach Ashley as she was
stumbling back from zay's second party
on September 14th and presumably a
couple weeks after that we saw Roxy type
the phrase and try to summon Smiley and
nothing happened so why didn't he show
up then is he just lazy does he only
show up when he feels like it and the
more I think about it the more the
ending starts to fall apart several
members of the smiley group faked their
deaths and went missing for several days
to sell the illusion to Ashley so what's
going to happen to that do they to
change their names and move to another
town isn't the FBI eventually going to
come looking for them and find them it
would certainly be strange if they all
just suddenly reappeared after Ashley's
death I was also somewhat misled by some
of the movies Marketing in the movie we
see the fake Smiley mask used by the
group with the black fabric cover on top
and the smooth skin face which I refer
to as real Smiley but in the trailer we
see a smooth Smiley mask on the ground
next to one of the nylon covers and then
in this ad there's just a smooth white
mask being worn by Ashley that we never
see in the movie but it doesn't end
there because the main poster shows a
headshot of of Smiley with this burlap
sack texture so to make things easy and
because I wouldn't consider marketing to
be canon in most cases anyway let's just
throw out everything that isn't in the
movie you know what let's throw out
these terrible press Stills too just
because they're cringe but there is one
line that I want to go back to oh God
something tells me smiley is going to be
really popular this Halloween it's going
to be historic people are going to be
speaking our names for Generations he
talks about Smiley leaving a legacy
being remembered for future Generations
my first thought was that this was
hilarious ious ly off the mark because
only 11 years later you have to jump
through hoops to even watch the movie
but as I poured more and more time into
this video about a character who I
thought would be forgotten by most and
maligned by those who do remember except
balls.com on letterbox who said I loved
hearing this from my room while on the I
started to discover something that
surprised me smiley is being remembered
pretty fondly no not the movie it's
nearly impossible to find a positive
review of that but rather the character
there is something creepy about the
featureless face with only that huge
unchanged ing smile stitched into it
like a man in agony trapped in a prison
of delightful expression the movie
released in October 2012 to universally
negative ACC claim and even managed to
piss off the real Anonymous allegedly
some of whom harassed and threatened
director Michael Gallagher but in the
years that followed it would be the icon
of smiley that persisted in pop culture
it started in November 2013 with YouTube
makeup artist Pink Stylist uploading a
smiley makeup tutorial based on
overwhelming viewer requests pink admits
that he's never seen the movie but
thought the character looked awesome
based on the advertisement which
definitely s and the video sits at 8.1
million views as a recording the
following year he took the look on
omegel to mess with people where he
ironically ran into a kid wearing an
anonymous mask a lot of people
recognized him as smiley as well
including one kid who tried to find out
what happens when you write I did it for
the luls while in a video chat with
smiling what's up behind
you the video has racked up an
astonishing 28 million views and as the
characters in the movie predicted the
legend only seemed to spread from there
binder specifically mentioned Smiley
Halloween costumes and this became kind
of phenomenon according to Michael
Gallagher he was receiving hundreds of
photos of smiley costumes 4 years later
in 2016 and people from all over the
world went to Smiley in 2017 the
popularity of the look persisted into
the next decade when special effects
artist Greg McDougall showed off and
explained the mask used in the movie
perhaps the biggest fan of smiley was
Minneapolis based Indie filmmaker Ryan
Zimmerman no not that Ryan Zimmerman who
began work on a fan film prequel called
Smiley origins in 2019 the original
smiley movie seems to already show the
origins of the character though so I'm
not sure what this movie was going to
entail because it hasn't come out there
was a trailer released in 2020 but
unfortunately as of April 2023 the
project seems to be on an indefinite
Hiatus even in this year as of recording
this video in 2023 Pink Stylist came
back with a Valentine's Day variant just
for the ls I guess it makes sense that
in a movie made by YouTubers and
featuring YouTubers the legacy of this
movie is essentially just this viral
character speaking of which the last
couple YouTuber cameos to point out are
seen in the random chat Partners on the
hide and go chat website a couple
notable ones are exotic Jess who
collaborated with a lot of big channels
back in the day another is Bri srig who
similarly found herself in a lot of
collabs including a stint with totally
sketch and she went on to be a host on
Source fat one thing that YouTube is
great for that traditional films aren't
is getting the audience involved so
that's exactly what Michael gallager did
for the other faces that appeared on the
chat site leave a video response of
yourself looking at your webcam bored
happy making faces whatever you want to
do and I might choose you to be in the
movie which is pretty cool and might be
the widest casting call ever created so
let's bring it back to the question that
I posed at the beginning of this video
does Smiley deserve all of the haes I
mean yeah kind of well maybe not all of
it it didn't live up to the hype it has
low ratings everywhere and you can't
even get it on streaming services
anymore which I found baffling because
having it available for streaming cost
them very little and even if nobody buys
it nothing is really lost I'm guessing
it has something to do with Shane Dawson
getting in controversy and Toby Turner
getting in controversy and the company
just deciding that it wasn't worth
potentially being connected to them for
a movie that wasn't bringing in any
meaningful Revenue anyway so they just
decided to try to erase it from the
public eye but if they knew anything
about the internet it's that nothing
goes away on the internet and smiley
continues to live on a decade later even
if the movie isn't the best there are a
couple of redeeming qualities so
hopefully this video helped you find
some appreciation for them Michael
Gallagher is far from a lost cause as a
director after this he went on to make
another movie with Shane Dawson called
internet famous then returned to the
horror genre to make two installments of
the thinning starring Logan Paul yeah
Michael Gallagher really knows how to
pick them y maybe if this video does
well I'll cover the thinning in the
future I haven't seen internet famous or
the thinning but let's just make one
thing clear Smiley isn't bad because
it's filled with YouTubers it's bad cuz
it's just bad it's low effort and it's
low budget you got to pick one or the
other and it seems that there was a lot
of inexperience in all areas of the crew
my first videos were definitely terrible
and this is a new medium for almost
everyone involved but let's not Overlook
that some of the best movies in recent
years have been made by YouTubers or
Star YouTubers lights out was one of the
most memorable horror movies of a strong
decade 8th grade was amazing Aquafina is
killing it I could go on and on it takes
a lot of dedication to build an audience
in a world where audiences can choose
whatever they want and I think those who
decide to cross over to Old School
Hollywood are going to continue to put
out some amazing stuff if you made it
this far in the video do me a favor and
write I did it for the luls three times
in the comments don't forget to check
out the merch store for my Shane Dawson
inspired horror merch and if you love
horror or if you just love YouTube make
sure you subscribe to cz's world for new
Horrors every week ring the death bell
for all notifications and I will see you
in the next one assuming we both survive